hi we're lucius and we're
thrilled to be here today um we're gonna
perform a new song of ours it's called
white lies
wrote it a couple weeks ago in
quarantine and hope you enjoy it
[Music]
in the middle of the night
when you're in the dark do you think
about me
and you why it was an art
but we could turn the lights down
if you want to see what it's like to
turn every moment to memory
i just wanna lie with you
[Music]
teach me
we both know how it ends there's nothing
to figure out
do i really need a reason if i
have no doubt
until nothing is left so let's just
pretend
for now
if you have to try to love me
if that's the way it's gonna be well at
least we can have right now
and it's bittersweet
i just wanna lie with you
[Music]
i just need you now we both know
how it is there's nothing to figure out
do i really need a reason if i have no
doubt
until nothing is left so let's just
pretend for now
[Music]
just this time
why
[Music]
is
do i really need a reason if i
have no doubt
[Music]
until nothing is left so let's just
pretend for now
[Music]
why
just
[Music]
just this time
this is a track off of our first record
wilder women and it's called turn it
[Music]
around
she can't be bothered
[Music]
turn it around
uh
[Music]
tray
and she's looking through the wrong
[Music]
without an option
[Applause]
[Music]
turn it around turn it around
oh
[Music]